d'être la
mascotte c'est c'est d'être supporteur
le plus
[Musique]
célèbre j'étais allé à la mosquée prier
maintenant je suis là pour récupérer les
tickets pour aller au stade
suivez-moi c'est bon
monsieur
[Musique]
c'est la mascotte du 12e Ganis c'est lui
tout à c'est rien c'esti c'est lui le
Tricolore du drapau National verion
rouge depuis ce temps j'essaie de
prendre le flambeau et je le tisse au
plus haut possible que je peu mais vous
savez moi ce que je fais je le fais avec
le cœur Cameroun dans la sauce dans la
sauce Cameroun dans la
[Musique]
sauce là on part à Nana derrière l'école
primaire pour vraiment se préparer pour
aller après au stade vous voyez hein ici
nous on habite de l'autre côté de la
fille puisque nous on s'est pris en
charge totale et
[Musique]
entière
ah c'est
[Musique]
la voilà bienvenue Bienvenue dans notre
quartier général là où on
loge là où on
[Musique]
loge bien on y va là vous vous préparez
là France 24 c'est France 24 les gars
ouais ça
[Musique]
va wou là je vous laisse je vais
m'habiller et je sors c'est
[Musique]
commence vous avez vu l'emlem c'est les
lion au
Sénégal le drapeau c'est la nation et le
chapeau que vous voyez comme ça le
chapeau je l'ai cristallisé en tant que
vous voyez il y a le Py ici ça
représente la pêche au Sénégal et vous
avez vu la carapite là ça représente le
transport sénégalais et là j'essaie de
capter le Sénégal en miniature et c'est
moi qui l'a conçu réfléchi et concu et
[Musique]
[Rires]
fabriqué partout là o je par dans le
monde c'est comme ça tout le monde vient
prendre des photos vers moi
[Musique]
partout